[Music]
these amateur insects lovers have been
busy studying both populations in
Germany for more than 30 years and their
fieldwork has confirmed something which
is alarming both amateur and
professional scientists alike the
entomologist from Krefeld observed a
nearly fivefold decline in pollinating
insects between 1994 and today nearly
90% of all flowering plants are
pollinated by animals and much of our
food depends on them from our breakfast
cereal to our beard versus in the 60%
level pins from al Stram thoughts
another extremely innocent have ignored
is the between summit and an insect
enticing a hefty devastated kite in our
oppa death convenience on the number of
[ __ ] brilliant suits will tame the
beam a trifle would have come stag
navona Shima and it's the thousands of
species of wild bees and insects like
hover flies and wasps which do the
legwork or the wing work to ensure that
crops are fertilized in bear fruit
vegetables nuts and cereals there are
some major drivers so one of the most
important ones is intensified land use
but also homogenization of land use and
also the kind of loss of structure in
landscapes but also climate change
placer all diseases as well an invasive
species Parliament is calling on the EU
to do more to protect insects and their
habitats via the EU pollinators
initiative MEP supported tighter
restrictions on harmful pesticides
responsible for insect decline and are
now calling on the Commission to do more
it isn't good Angeles garnish candy to
make which like clean our escape divide
cannot define religion amongst taxes or
pests in the rain by dark get this
closer looking on top was the commercial
yourself leaf on Parliament will now
examine the steps the EU needs to take
to protect Europe's biodiversity economy
and food security
[Music]